nightlife
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and uh
Thanksgiving time that's it okay yeah
yeah so your big things are um social
media and nightlife nightlife yeah and
the all the whole behaviors of the
window all the whole behavior is gone
what do you want a wife a hoe no no no
is it possible too I don't know
um okay what would you expect your girl
um to give up for you
um I'm pretty liberal like unless I see
that is coming between us in some way do
what you want just don't be out here
making e-reverse look crazy because
you're a reflection of me
so if you're gonna go to the club with
your girls all right cool but then if it
if I if it comes back to me like you was
dancing on 50 men and your tongue was
down 50 throats then obviously it's not
gonna run can it because one man
too many I should be the one man and if
I'm not that obviously it's not always
that I can be there but like I'm not
gonna she's dancing on another dude what
do you mean you're dancing on a no she's
at the club
that's almost like a sarcastic refrain
but I understand what you mean by she's
dancing on another one but like I
wouldn't appreciate that
yeah of course not working or nothing
nobody's thinking about it yeah sure
yeah because you know it is now yeah
have you have you kept a girl before
that's done well yeah that's the thing
oh okay and I was like you know what
it's a dance if I she told me she didn't
tell me though so it's like cool you
told me
is it their worst thing in the world no
did I appreciate it no
you didn't matter did you I did Mario
that's the thing oh she's the oh yeah
yeah this is my wife yeah okay yeah so
but then to be fair with my wife because
the story with my wife is a long time in
the making like I met my wife when I was
seven years old like so it's different
yeah you know so like exactly but then
I've said to her before like if I just
if I met you in the club and then I
found like you went to the club and
using other things in the club because I
just you're just any girl from the club
so you can go but she doesn't do that
now no no no she now when she's like oh
she's meeting her boyfriend's like yeah
go because she's a wife she's a mother
she's the education and stuff like she's
very rarely goes out she looks after me
Foods clothes all that kind of a more
traditional relationships very very to
be fair yeah so and yeah so
that's that's why I would question it
but obviously my situation is very
unique as as opposed to some other
people out there but in general terms
then I would most people say yeah okay
uh what would you give up for the right
guy
not soccer
pretty much my daughter and football is
like those two things I mean why would a
man want me to give up football I mean
yeah
um but I don't I mean I don't even keep
social media on my main phone I don't
I did a lot of clubbing when I was
younger I've
got my life scene I mean I'm easy yeah
whatever I don't have to
dress like a slot but then what if your
husband was like no yeah so you need to
hang up your football boots
no more lives no more life coaching just
sit down then we'll calculate get up and
cook yeah if it's the right man like
sure I'm bored of coaching anyway
you won't give up you just won't do it
because you don't want to do it anymore
right
it's not like give up for him you're
coaching well I am doing it now but yeah
if he really wanted me to give for the
right man yeah I would I'm not really
okay I have a question so this one I
actually don't even
I don't think I would do this one so so
would you get plastic surgery no for the
right guy no I would not give up no no
no that I would not that doesn't really
make sense to me because if the guy
wants you to get plastic surgery why
don't you just find the woman who looks
like that's the way yeah yeah I've heard
I've heard guys like paying for their
girl's boob jobs yeah 100 yeah I've
heard of that that's awesome I'm too
scared to go under surgery
but I think that's my I might need it
but
the front is your arm and all that
plastic surgery BBL bll but yeah
otherwise I'm easy I'm not attached to
um
couldn't he just get the girl to eat
more not you can't get boobs from that
no yeah
wouldn't your breasts grow yeah I don't
think they why like I think it's usually
because they want the shape yeah
I don't know
yeah no you can't there are ways that
you can but not for it to look like
plastic no obviously not that's not
gonna be up here but like but there are
things you like I said it is you can
work on yourself and get that I would do
that for him like to like work on myself
to be in shape to look good yeah
absolutely but not plastic surgery or
fillers yeah
um okay what would you expect the right
girl to do for you I already give up for
you
um I think you know sort of to begin
with
um just to look at my current
circumstances obviously if she'd work
let's start the other is fine but if it
came down to where I was in a position
where she wouldn't need to work
and especially I think
I think by Nature like I want to be the
woman that's more nurturing so you know
that early stages before the kids start
to go to school
I'll take one for the team you know you
gotta stay at home especially if I can
provide that life for us you know so
that's what I expected to give after
that you know we're open to talks she
wants to go back to work get a little
problem but in that period
gotta play ball man you know if it's the
best thing for the family yeah
did you answer what you would give up
for the right guy I don't remember no
not really okay because I was thinking
about it and it was kind of like um
I don't know I probably
wouldn't give up anything nothing no
okay relationships require sex no I
haven't I I have a fiance obviously and
I love him but the I think the the only
reason probably is coming from that that
is he's very he he wants me the way I
want I am I mean
um I think I love dancing so he doesn't
me going to there because I do a bit of
a TV personality in Persian channels so
I do a lot of dancing I do a lot of you
know cameras I do like Persian Latinos I
mix both I will I will do a bit of a
dance here and so because because I do
whatever I always wanted to do right now
and he's very happy with the way I am
even though I'm most of the time just
you know I'm very like outgoing and
stuff and spending a lot of time out
because of the camera and videos and my
friends
um and he's always involved and he's
loving the fact that I'm very outgoing
and social so he doesn't say oh I don't
like that don't do that don't do this so
I think maybe it's you do whatever you
want so probably if he tells me don't
dance I wouldn't give up because I'm I'm
so what if he told you delete social
media
hmm would you would you get social media
for social media because I have a big
platform on Instagram and I really
worked hard for it do you make any
Revenue any type of money do you get
paid from social media
no but I have a big amazing family it's
like you know you're having when you
build up your Instagram you can call the
Family sorry you can call it firm in the
first time your family oh I don't want
my family in Iran I I called Instagram
my family as well because I I kind of
like hold on better than your real
family like your fiance no I just don't
understand why anybody wants me to
delete my Instagram in case you can see
them in real life yeah well it's easy
yeah we had we had um a guy um come come
in um uh two days ago uh Justin Waller
he's like a YouTuber and this guy has
married women
um constantly trying to sleep with him
on social media all the time like
literally like he's shown me like videos
pictures of girls like saying come over
and like he'll show me pictures of their
families right yeah and he doesn't do it
because he's he's not that type of guy
yeah you know yeah but but
it's like if a guy just wants to avoid
that headache yeah of you you know
potentially doing something like you
wouldn't understand that if a lot of um
divorces like come from social media
that's true because my sister had you
know lots of argue with his with her
husband because of social media but now
thinking about it if obviously he wants
me to delete Instagram otherwise he's
not going to be with me because I I
really love him and he's he's amazing so
probably I would but I think I'm going
to be depressed
is he Iranian no he's English okay okay
we don't have that sort of things in
your life you don't really think about
it but now because we're discussing it
it's actually good for me because when
you discuss it I get into myself and
thinking if one their dad want me to
delete my Instagram because we never had
that conversation and I never thought
about it but now you're asking me and
I'm thinking about it probably I would
but I can ask you would you like give
would you give up just pearly things for
the right shoes oh yeah easily yeah I
mean to be honest I would I would really
want to get my
could just do at home though from home
yeah I mean to be honest I don't think
the show is conducive like what am I
gonna do this when I have kids no
I would still the wife show you could
still do oh yeah
why school you can still do that then
yeah just drop the baby with your foot
here
I mean if it was genuinely causing a
problem in my marriage like I would no I
mean it's social media you know what I
mean that's what I was gonna say I don't
know sorry yeah go ahead I was gonna say
I don't understand why social media has
such a grip on people nailed it hasn't
been around for that long it's only what
9 10. imagine saying that 10 year old
controls your life and it isn't your
child that is crazy to me like yeah fair
enough I'll go on social media most days
that I'm scrolling when you actually
really think about what is it that
you're doing unless like you're a
full-time content creator now or like
some form of celebrity where you need to
have that level of Engagement to my mind
now if you're just on then going like
this on with your thing with your thumb
scrolling in the glass that's why
wasting your time no I I wouldn't if I
was like that like just scrolling and
you know wasting my time I wouldn't even
care if I want to delete my Instagram
yeah what about girls trips would you
give up girls trips 100
10 nights yes but I love my grocery
actually tonight when I go home I'm
gonna go on a holiday I'm gonna ask him
if if there's one thing he wants me to
give up on what would it be I don't know
I should ask him I think you should
exactly
what if he came back and said now that
you asked yeah
and this
oh well no it's actually interesting you
make me kind of like aware of what about
plastic surgery would you get plastic
surgery for a guy if if like I I did my
boob job because after I had Neda I just
lost the fat because I lost weight and I
did it for myself because I hated it and
I wanted to do it but um if I had to do
it because of
him
no not really no I'm scared of plastic
surgeries I mean I did this 10 years ago
but now I'm getting older and I'm scared
of that sort of thing okay
um did you say what you would give up
for a guy you know what this actually
this conversation made me think when I
was younger we actually were women we do
that we do give up things we why do we
dress a certain way
to for men to look at us and I think you
know I think there was times when I was
too conscious of I wanna be a certain
way so I can get the attention from men
but no that's not the case anymore
that's why I can speak freely about this
uh if I would get plastic surgery no
giving up things like my social media my
career yes
but when it comes to I don't know this
is it's just
as well because I now I'm thinking when
it was about 2025 and I had a boyfriend
and I fell in love with him and to be
honest I would have done anything but
not now were you more in love then
probably
okay so so it sounds like four
the like the right guy you would give up
more yeah
I mean I don't know is it a is it
changed or am I wrong is it the Age
It's gotta be the right guy the only the
guy it should be your age as well yeah
but it's the opposite it was I don't
know maybe like I was raised by a
feminist mom and he was like don't get
married don't have kids go and do it
I know no but she's very happy she's got
a granddaughter I'm the only one out of
her four kids who's given her a
grandchild could it be because when you
get older when you get more experience
experience and you get more confident
you kind of feel like why do I have to
do that well maybe because maybe because
you don't love you that much if I did
have that much I don't call it I don't I
don't think it's love only no I don't
think I should do something because I
should do my boob job because I love him
and he wants me to do it I don't call it
love if he would really truly love me he
would love me the way I look yeah that
could be my ideal man like I've got a
second there you know this does not want
me to have a I just don't like all that
any of that stuff anyway but so I think
I call it my um I'm I'm more mature in
terms of making decisions rather than
just because someone maybe I would have
I I have maybe I would have tell him
wait blessing I have to give a statement
um okay is camera is Michael here
can you see if he'll take the show for
like while I go do it I have to give a
police statement I guess for the lady
called the police yeah I'm so sorry bro
serious yeah but guys we're gonna get
King Richie's to take over the show yes
um it's ridiculous
seriously yeah I guess she couldn't just
out of Mercy are you sure it's not a
crackhead in a police Outfield
[Music]
she just
yeah she went off and then she was
trying to say that I said that domestic
abuse was okay I didn't even I don't
know where she got these these ideas
in my head yeah they were saying a lot
of great things and going off of random
tangents as well and just not even just
listening so how tall are you before I
go I wanted to hear so you said you had
a feminist mother when did you because
you seem actually pretty based
well yeah I was born 1980. so I grew up
in the 90s and
yeah moving from Iran
um to Sweden it was my mom was like
Freedom do what you want was your mom a
single mother
um it's flat when I was 12. she couldn't
divorced my dad and had two jobs two
three jobs and you know really tried to
provide for us really good Mom amazing I
love her but she really um I said to her
my only complaint was like You Raised Me
based on ideologies that you had not you
know I never really got you it was more
what you believed in about you know
being a feminist being an atheist and
um
so yeah and I um
yeah I'm definitely a lot of feminist
right here so I'm curious do you feel
did your mom ever get remarried no she
was with someone for like 20 years but
not she didn't get remarried oh okay so
it's yeah I was just wondering if she
had a better outcome or not I've always
wondered about that when sorry no
um and that's not direct to you
personally but because I grew up single
parent home but I've always wondered
where they told that they were out there
working two three jobs yeah I'll sing
them up and then telling her daughter to
go out and do the same I just I don't
understand how okay yeah
I mean I've worked two three jobs before
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible